it was a a very big surprise no I
I had really discard that the
possibility of receiving the Nobel Prize
I was in New York at that time because I
was teaching at Princeton but living in
New York I usually start to work very
early it was 5:00 in the morning I think
I was preparing a lesson that I had to
deliver the next day it was I think five
five and suddenly I saw my wife appear
what I was working with a telephone and
with a very strange attitude like if she
was having a kind of mystical clan's you
know she didn't say a word and she gave
me the telephone and what was funny is I
thought immediately something of the
somewhere someone in the family is very
ill or is dead because of 5:00 in the
morning and then I took the telephone
and I couldn't hear anything because
there were all kind of electric you know
sounds and but suddenly I heard very far
away Swedish Academy then I was got so I
said why why he has said Swedish Academy
she was still in a state of trance you
know mystical transom and immediately
after the the telephone rang again and
this time I could speak and I was told
where I am the the Secretary of the
Swedish Academy and you have received
the Nobel Prize of literature and I was
so surprised that I could only react
quit and a stupid question I said is
that official and I was told it will be
in half an hour
open the radio or the television and you
will see it was and and we were talking
with my wanna see that do you think this
is true
and I remember that we were in Rome
several years ago in which there was a
fantastic misunderstanding because an
Italian writer had received a call like
this and he was naive enough to call the
press to say I've been told that I have
received the Nobel Prize and it wasn't
true it was a job that has been played
on him back his so-called friends and
and we were talking and and I said and
what about this is a kind of joke like
the job that was done to Moravia to
Alberto Moravia no but then we were
acetate in if we would call our children
or we expected you know the half an hour
and but finally we decided that it was
true and so we call our two sons and our
daughter they were very surprised of
course and at six o'clock new your time
it was given the news everywhere in
radios in TV and and what was even more
incredible is it half an hour later I
had at least 20 newspaper man at the
door of my apartment in New York
6:30 in the morning you know mostly from
Nordic TVs and radio stations that a
Norwegian
Sweden it was incredible you know and I
am still thinking if this is true world
it is a kind of fairy tale that I've
been living since in earth